bonjour madame bonjour voila j'ai acheté
ces chiens et il ya un problème mais
vous l'avez acheté qu il ya trois
semaines
bonjour madame
un beau jour qu'est-ce qui se passe
madame a acheté son chiot il ya trois
semaines on lapide à huîtres bien je
vous demande de faire quelque chose oui
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour vous
mesdames une maladie
oui c'est l'exact je pense il tenir vous
madame vous êtes vétérinaire c'est pas
la question mais si c'est la question à
votre chien vous rendez chez le véto
milova classement en règle n'a rien à se
reprocher vous savez ça arrive que
certains réagissent propres actions
c'est rare mais ça arrive
nous on n'est pas responsable de sa non
plus hein tu m'aides
et je peux pas le changer avec un autre
mais un pneu n'aime pas changer vos
enfants soient plus simples